hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba John Humphrey is me we are
gonna watch a top reward tier request
I'm so happy it's here it's from a
patron of our she's been here for a
little bit now named Jenny Corona from
Malta he does reactions the extra to
reaction to our up game sketch you see
it was really funny yeah this guy's
great he makes some little sketches to
go check out his channel I think he
likes laughs he's on his game of Thrones
reactions or something this sketch is
yes and this sketch is called Lord of
the Thrones unfinished business
let's see what we got over
good fate effect
what car you an ice cream
you mean right like a chocolate tart so
no
[Music]
push the blood out of your mouth look
push this out
[Music]
[Music]
I was serious
it's a really professional screenplay
screamed we open on a field with a dye
job with a Targaryen
[Music]
vengers so this is the first of many is
that what it is it says John will return
so I mean I can only assume that there's
gonna be a second well I mean at least
one more because there's the finale I
don't know how this is going to continue
once Game of Thrones ends but it
certainly seems a bit more lore of the
Rings inspired at the moment danesco
this looks like you had the most fun
doing this yes how did you craft this
screenplay together of Jenny how'd you
guys pull this off I guess that Unicorn
how'd you get the Unicorn
how did you get the nazgûl that's what
it's called black rider how'd you get
that going
I want to live in Malta I feel like this
is like down the street from where
backyard yeah yeah like everywhere it
looks like a destination are these your
buds are these your mates no these are
actual professional actors they hire to
work at the local theatre are these
people that you met at rent
no I this took me back to making shorts
in the old days where just like you can
you have feel like the sort of here you
grab the camera and we'll get a shot
over here yeah yeah I think it was just
these three people who made and that's
the way it should be forever and I keep
it going John and I have expanded our
crew for short films to five give or
take I feel like it's kind of like Oh
God grown and then subtracted but they
have also gotten people who can do
multiple jobs now so yeah yeah five or
six people five or six yeah but keep it
at this solid three for a while this is
really amusing this was charming in a
way I don't quite know what happened
other than he know the nazgûl and then
the nazgûl killed him he's like it's
almost as if I was reading one of the
books yeah where I don't know what I'm
reading but I'm sure fans are enjoying
it it's like there are a lot of
descriptions of fields and battles to
drink as I'm sure I mean literally
there's something in the note that I'm
not getting because this video has over
a thousand views and only I just hit the
like button but now there's 36 I'll
focus on a single dislike so you must be
doing something right buddy I don't get
it but I was definitely charmed it was
like a roller coaster of magic well my
favourite bit wasn't the nazgûl grab the
unicorn because because he had to
anticipate that these kind of jokes
always work best when you're being
self-aware and are aware of that you
have no budget and that your people with
a camcorder just messing around
yeah so keep it up dude this is just the
beginning and don't ever cut that
beautiful hair that you grew up for this
video yeah it looks great and I went
full committed and dotted and everything
to like if you watch our sketch they're
furtively actually a reaction to our
very first sketch that we ever put
together and your sketches remind me of
that so keep evolving keep growing I
feel like our senses of humor are
ultimately aligned but guys if you
haven't seen any of em Jenny's videos
please do you go wait no I did see one
of his other sketches this makes a
little bit more sense than well actually
it wasn't a sketch of something kind of
weird what he did was he went on the
street and talked to people with that
unicorn
oh yeah do you think a unicorn will
appear in Game of Thrones and rule of
Westeros yeah yeah and then he had a
like this weird 3d animation with like
Jon Snow sitting on the Iron Throne with
a dragon behind it saying like do you
think this will happen so I guess that's
the one I think it yeah it happened this
it's happening this is more canon than
the series itself this is a spoiler hey
guys if you don't want to know anything
about the lorry
going up to random people on the street
for the camera has always been daunting
to me maybe we should do it sometime
yeah let's try it well just go around
going Do You Know Who I am
Do You Know Who I am do you watch
YouTube too much videos and every person
going no but my cousin John yeah yeah
we're just gonna relive your Tyrone and
Tom Holland experience over again a lot
of pictures of me and other people well
anyway
Jeffie thanks for sending that video our
way you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell to
get updated every time a review or a
video is out and does subscribe to us on
patreon we got weekly stuff and all
sorts of exclusives it's a lot of fun
great people would love for you to
become a patreon addicted a piece